we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P here's a call of very
concise and pithy question
hey David a declared Republican
candidate who is the most reasonable
candidate in your opinion thanks for all
you do man it's Chris Christie as we
talked about earlier it's so obvious who
is the most reasonable Republican
candidate it is Chris Christie a
relatively moderate former Governor from
New Jersey who understands the reality
that to get the Republican nomination
you have to go through Trump
yes he is a self-aggrandizing sort of
guy but he's at least willing to admit
some mistakes as he did during
yesterday's Town Hall event
he understands even if I disagree with
him on the solutions he understands
issues in a far deeper way than many of
these other people that are running and
uh that is probably why he's polling one
percent at least right now he just
announced we don't have any announce any
polling from after Christie's
announcement it'll be interesting to see
in 10 to 14 days whether the polling
moves at all he's pulling one percent
right now
if you came to me and you said David the
next president will be one of these
Republicans it won't be Joe Biden it'll
be one of these Republicans who do you
want to see as president it is obviously
and undoubtedly Chris Christie from the
current slate of Republicans if you
disagree with me please let me know we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today lying Congressman George Anthony
devolder Santos has lost his attempt to
Shield the people who gave him his bail
money
um he is no longer going to be able to
keep them secret that is fascinating who
might they be we will discuss Oklahoma
has okayed its first religious charter
school and this immediately is setting
up a war over separation of church and
state because taxpayer money is used for
that charter school and a Texas sheriff
is recommending criminal charges over
the Ron DeSantis migrant flight stunt
who would be charged and when and for
what crimes we will tell you on the
bonus show sign up at Joe joinpakman.com
it is the world famous and award-winning
bonus show admittedly they are all
Awards we give out but they are still
great I'll see you then or back on the
program tomorrow